thank you so much i know it's not me
today it's
i love you too
thank you
but it's it's
i know
it's not me
it's the fact that it's gonna rain here
it's gonna rain and they say
they said it could end our wildfire
season oh my gosh but of course this is
california so it has to turn into a
disaster
they say after that we're gonna get
flooding and landslides
on the plus side in san francisco it'll
wash the [ __ ] off the street so you know
oh i did
i kid the [ __ ] on the street
also some pretty great news hawaii
the state just announced they're going
to open back up to the fully vaccinated
next month yes finally
finally a governor who is asking the
right questions about covet like how
will my policies affect bill maher's new
year's eve plans
that's right our hawaii gig is back on
our 10th anniversary
okay so yes look i mean we're i think
over the hump here yet now i read
there's a new strain of kova did you see
this delta plus
okay people there's always going to be a
new strain
it's a virus okay it's going to try to
live
we got to live we got to try to live
yes thank
you because there's so many
repercussions i mean
psychiatrists and pediatricians now
saying there's a national mental health
emergency with the young with the youth
of america sullen withdrawn full of
anxiety and then covet hit
uh
but
but they say it's it's ten times worse
now i i i heard a mother at the dinner
table the united say honey are you okay
you've barely taken a picture of your
food
[Applause]
what was i doing in someone's house
observing that it's weird i just walked
into a house and i needed a joke i
walked in
but no there's a shortage of everything
now have you seen this this is our new
crisis in america and uh biden he's had
it up to here he no he lost his temper
this week i mean between the
reconciliation bill stuck with would
preen between the democrats isn't even
up to the republicans yet and all the
shortages he did he lost it biden said
what are we doing he said this is the
united states of america damn it
and i thought it was kind of sweet he's
so old he remembers when it was weird to
think of america as a huge fuck-up
[Applause]
republicans now are trying to paint him
as jimmy carter 2.0 does anybody
remember jimmy carter and they say it's
the 70s all over again well you know
inflation is going up gas prices
shortages biden would not have anybody
said that is ridiculous this is not the
1970s
and then his mood ring turned black that
was a bad sign
remember the mood ring i barely do
[Applause]
but are you excited about halloween this
is the great
[Applause]
are
time
this is a great time of year when you're
excited about your costume but it hasn't
gotten you canceled yet
so you
that's it there are some people out
there celebrities
politics some great costumes coming up
rudy giuliani is going as a lawyer
yeah
tucker tucker carlson's going as a
journalist this year so
amazing the way
and kirsten cinema is going as a
democrat it's going to be a really
interesting halloween
now the committee that's looking into
the january 6th uprising of the capitol
hill riot uh has subpoenaed steve bannon
former guest many times here's steve
bannon
great to see you out steve that's good
to see you wearing the three shirts good
to have you
of course bannon told him to piss up a
rope
a subpoena piss up a rope but but he
said but not this rope this is my mike
pence hanging rope
hey
speaking of a quick correction i
mentioned this on our last show that
steve bannon was subpoenaed and he said
i'm not coming and i said eric holder
and janet reno did that turned out that
was wrong a correction we don't usually
do this because we have a crack staff on
crack
but that's not true eric calder did
justify nine times in the [ __ ] fast
and furious thing anyway trump is
starting listen to this starting his own
social media network
i love the title it's called truth
social
[Applause]
apparently [ __ ] my dad says was taken
and i love
i love this one of the one of the rules
on truth social is you can't use truth
social to make fun of truth social
because if it's if anything republicans
love it's free speech
and if it's anything they hate it's
snowflakes
you